[Musik]
die papiere bitte ab heute gilt die
einreisesperre
und wer jetzt noch aus corona mutations
gebieten nach deutschland kommt muss
schon ganz besondere gründe haben
ein leben vom bildschirm für jugendliche
spielt sich im shutdown von schule bis
freizeit fast alles digital ab experten
warnen und tropen wind trifft polarluft
das teil das land in zwei hälften in den
verregneten süden mit hochwasser und den
verschneiten norden mit rodelpisten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen an
diesem samstag bei heute und auch
norbert lehmann ist wieder mit von der
partie kein schimmel beim dorfturnier
lassen sich wehren aussperren
die bundesregierung versucht ist wer aus
einem land kommt in dem sich die
aggressiveren corona mutanten verbreitet
haben darf nicht mehr einreisen
es sei dies zwar eine drastische
maßnahme sagt innenminister seehofer
aber zum schutz der bevölkerung absolut
notwendig außerdem sei jetzt
bürgerpflicht auf jeden nicht zwingende
reise zu verzichten
deutsche dürfen zwar zurückkehren wenn
sie aus einem der betroffenen länder
kommen aber sonst sind die grenzen
weitgehend dicht
in europa gilt das für die britischen
inseln also großbritannien und irland
dazu kommt portugal wo sich die
britische virusvariante rasant
ausbreitet weltweit stehen brasilien
sowie südafrika auf der liste welche
auswirkungen die sperren haben zeigt
susanne santina da auch großbritannien
zu den vom einreiseverbot betroffenen
ländern zählt wurden die passagiere aus
manchester am geht gleich von der
polizei empfangen die kontrollierte
nicht nur bei ihnen ein negativer
pcr-test vorlag sondern auch die
einreisepapiere nur wer deutscher
staatsbürger ist oder hier eine
aufenthaltserlaubnis hat durfte
einreisen
viele waren über die strengen kontrollen
überrascht wir waren jetzt auch ganze
von komatsu in england und jetzt wieder
in deutschland zu sein und dann so
empfangen zu werden ist natürlich ein
schock wir haben ja wo wir gegangen sind
ganz gut so was gerechnet ich muss sagen
ich finde es angemessen wenn ich das mit
england vergleiche muss ich sagen dass
die leute ist dort nicht so ernst
genommen haben insgesamt zwölf flüge kam
heute in frankfurt ausländern an die von
der einreisesperre betroffen sind
keiner musste hier abgewiesen werden
anders berichten ist passagiere die in
düsseldorf landeten am flughafen
lissabon hätten sich zum teil chaotische
szenen abgespielt
wenn man sich offensichtlich in der
situation noch nicht so richtig zurecht
fand und fiel aus reisende wieder
abgewiesen worden weil sie nicht genau
wussten wie die ich sag mal vorschriften
und regeln im augenblick sind
fest steht die fluggesellschaften sind
verpflichtet schon vor abflug alle
erforderlichen papiere zu kontrollieren
wir appellieren dringend an die airline
sie auflagen zu befolgen weil es hilft
uns alle die pandemie zu bekämpfen und
vor allen dingen insbesondere zu
verhindern dass das mutierte virus nach
deutschland eingeschleppt wird die neuen
einreisesperren sollen erst mal bis zum
februar gelten sie werden auch dafür
sorgen dass an den flughäfen noch
weniger passagiere ankommen
die einreisesperre wer ist davon
ausgenommen
und welche einreisebeschränkungen gelten
sonst noch diese und weitere details zum
nachlesen finden sie jederzeit online in
unserer zdf heute schauen wir jetzt nach
südafrika also in eines der länder das
von den reisebeschränkungen betroffen
ist die hoch ansteckende virus variante
breitet sich dort rasend schnell aus und
lässt die infektionszahlen massiv
ansteigen aus südafrika berichtet sandra
theis hochbetrieb auf einem friedhof in
johannesburg die bestatter kommen kaum
hinterher die toten unter die erde zu
bringen so viele sind es die zahlen
sprechen sehr laut für sich selbst
sie zeigen dass da etwas neu und ernst
ist etwas das diese hohe sterblichkeit
hervorruft wir setzen all unsere
hoffnung auf den impfstoff landesweit
sind rund 40.000 menschen offiziell an
cupid gestorben
die dunkelziffer dürfte deutlich höher
liegen dafür spricht die enorme zahl der
so genannten zusätzlichen toten in
südafrika sind berichten zufolge allein
im vergangenen jahr rund 80.000 menschen
zusätzlich gestorben es geht um tote die
es statistisch gesehen im vergleich zu
den vorjahren nicht hätte geben dürfen
experten gehen davon aus dass die
mehrheit von ihnen an oder durch ko wird
gestorben ist grund für die hohen
totenzahlen ist offenbar die neue
südafrikanische variante des virus
sie ist laut forschern zwar nicht töten
verbreitet sich aber rasend schnell aus
viele krankenhäuser sind völlig
überlastet patienten werden teilweise in
zelten behandelt manchmal erst mit
verzögerung es fehlt an personal betten
und beatmungsgeräten unsere stationen
sind voll es ist sehr schmerzhaft wenn
jemand in der notaufnahme ist damit eher
ein bett bekommt muss jemand sterben
außerdem fehlt es teilweise an
hochwertiger schutzausrüstung unter den
vielen toten sind auch hunderte
krankenschwestern und ärzte die sich
infiziert haben
und was machen die korona zahlen bei uns
hier setzt sich der positive trend fort
die gesamtzahl der neuinfektionen geht
weiter zurück
das robert koch institut meldet 12.300
21 neue krone infektionen binnen 24
stunden das sind 4096 weniger als
vergangenen samstag 794 weitere menschen
sind in verbindung mit dem virus
gestorben
die hoffnung ruht ja auf dem impfen und
da soll es jetzt schneller gehen nach
angaben des gesundheitsministeriums
werden bis zum 22
februar 1,7 millionen impfdosen mehr als
ursprünglich geplant geliefert und
gesundheitsminister sparen kündigte an
man werde die impfverordnung
überarbeiten
hintergrund ist die empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission den impfstoff
von astrazeneca nur bei unter
65-jährigen einzusetzen weil nicht
ausrechnen ausreichend belegt sei dass
er auch bei über 65-jährigen wird als
ex-us-präsident trump letzten herbst
eine corona infektion bekam erholte er
sich ziemlich schnell und behauptete er
habe ein wundermittel bekommen gemeint
hatte trump spezielle teure antikörper
medikamente von zwei us herstellern
inzwischen ist klar wunder arzneien sind
es nicht aber sie helfen wohl bei
bestimmten cupid 19 verläufen
deshalb hat die bundesregierung jetzt
200.000 dosen gekauft für 400 mio
euro und stellt sie ab sofort
ausgewählten kliniken zur verfügung
peter böhme diese frau ist doppelt
getroffen sie hat multiple sklerose und
seit ein paar tagen auch noch cobit 19
eine gefährliche kombination womit
könnte für einen krankheitsschub ihrer
ms sorgen und cupid könnte selbst zu
einer tödlichen bedrohung werden
und so bekam sie heute als eine der
ersten patienten hierzulande ein neues
medikament auf basis künstlich
hergestellter antikörper per infusion im
bochumer st josefs hospital
es geht um zeitgewinn bei denen es
wichtig ist dass überbrücken und genau
das sollen diese von außen zugeführten
antikörper bewirken
sie bewirken eine überbrückung bis
unsere eigenen antikörper da sind gruner
viren haben so genanntes bike proteine
die an die körperzellen andocken und die
viren eindringen lassen die antikörper
heften sich an die spike proteine und
verhindern das eindringen in die zellen
bisher ist die therapie in der eu noch
gar nicht zugelassen weil zu wenig
erforscht
doch das bundesgesundheitsministerium
erlaubt den einsatz nach bewertung der
zuständigen bundesoberbehörde dem
paul-ehrlich-institut liszt das
ermittelte sicherheitsprofil eine
anwendung nach individueller nutzen
risiko einschätzung in deutschland
grundsätzlich zu die patientin in bochum
sagt sie sehe für sich er den nutzen als
das risiko und hoffe glimpflich
davonzukommen
der krankheitsverlauf ist bisher mild
und genau bei solchen erkrankten scheint
die therapie anzusprechen
für patienten die einen leichten oder
mittleren verlauf haben patienten die an
schwerem verlauf haben gibt es keine
hinweise dass es dann auch eine günstige
wirkung gilt ein medikament immerhin
gegen korona weitere studien müssen nun
folgen kanzlerin merkel hat die korona
krise als gewaltigen kraftakt für
familien bezeichnet und um vorsicht und
geduld geworben
die bundesregierung setze alles daran
bullen und kitas als erstes wieder zu
öffnen aber noch sei es nicht so weit
die kanzlerin verwies auf die reale
gefahr durch die hochansteckenden virus
varianten
werfen wir einen genaueren blick auf die
situation von jugendlichen elearning
stadtschule chatten statt freunde
treffen
so sieht ihr leben gerade aus es findet
sozusagen online statt
schon im vergangenen sommer waren zwölf
bis 19 jährige in deutschland viel mehr
im netz als sonst und zwar gut vier
stunden täglich knapp eine stunde mehr
als im jahr davor
jetzt im winter dürfte die
internetnutzung noch intensiver sein
experten sind besorgt dominik müller
rosell berichtet acht uhr morgens geht's
los laptop hochfahren einloggen in dem
video unterricht für celine durmus und
millionen weitere kinder und jugendliche
findet alles digital statt freunde
treffen und verwandte spielen lernen
schule ein leben vor dem bildschirm
gewöhnt man sich halt irgendwann dran
und wenn man irgendwie damit klarkommt
muss man sagen dann ist es ja auch alles
gut es funktioniert aber es ist
natürlich trotzdem anstrengend wenn man
dann wirklich mehrere stunden täglich
und wirklich sehr oft dann vor dem
bildschirm sitzt egal ob es an
konferenzen sind ops unterricht ist aber
mit freunden telefoniert insgesamt ist
sehr bildschirmzeit berlin durmus geht
in die elfte klasse
sie ist gerade 70 geworden an ihrer
schule in hürth bei köln bemühen sich
ihre lehrer nicht den ganzen unterricht
per video stattfinden zu lassen sondern
immer wieder bildschirm pausen
einzustreuen das finden auch der einzel
arbeitsphasen stadt wo man dann wiederum
nicht mit dem rechner arbeitet das heißt
die zeiten sind schon in der summe
glaube ich hoch und das wir muss man das
im blick haben um bei diesen hohen zeit
das irgendwie zu minimieren haben
freunde treffen auch online
gerade weil das ganze leben so digital
geworden ist ist es umso wichtiger immer
wieder abzuschalten empfehlen experten
mein rat an die eltern ist machen sie
bildschirm freie zeiten aus und halten
sie sich auch selber tragen geben sie
beispiel indem sie selber ihr handy mal
zur seite legen sie werden feststellen
die welt geht gar nicht unter und
animieren sie kinder dazu auch mal eine
bewegungspause zu machen
sally durmus achtet selbst darauf wenn
sie merkt dass sie den kopf frei kriegen
muss geht sie hieraus fußball spielen
aufregung in göttingen mehr als 8000
menschen mussten heute mitten im
shutdown die eigene wohnung verlassen
der grund in der innenstadt waren
mehrere weltkriegsbomben geortet worden
darunter zwei amerikanische
zehn-zentner-bombe sie müssen
kontrolliert gesprengt werden
die behörden richteten mehrere
evakuierungszentren 1
die krone bestimmungen waren wegen der
sondersituation und gelockert worden und
jetzt ein blick aufs wetter da bleibt
deutschland zweigeteilt im süden und
westen regen sehr viel regen und das
heißt dann auch hochwasser in der mitte
und im norden eine weiße
winterlandschaft ralf schipanski
berichtet klirrend kalt und weiß wie
lange nicht erwacht am morgen im alten
land der neue tag
es ist als stehe die zeit hier hinterm
deich noch ein bisschen stiller als
sonst zu deutlich mehr andrang verlockte
schnee in hamburg im schanzenpark kamen
erst die familien dann die polizei
zunächst appelliert sie noch und lässt
laufen
ich bin super schönes wetter sollen die
zunächst ganz hervorragend dann aber
kommt doch das absperrband schluss mit
schlitten spaß es wird einfach zu voll
in der südhälfte deutschlands haben sie
andere sorgen statt schnee kommt das
wasser schnell und unerbittlich sie
hatten nur minuten da war die altstadt
von büdingen in hessen meter hoch
überflutet
und auch wenn das wasser wieder abfließt
das chaos ist noch da immerhin gelindert
durch prompte nachbarschaftshilfe
also erstmal bin ich dankbar dass
spontan so viele leute gekommen sind zum
helden ja das ist einfach auch ohne
gutachter weiß jeder hier die schäden
sind dramatisch hoch und es brauen sich
weitere fluten zusammen
der rhein bei karlsruhe ist für die
schifffahrt gesperrt
830 mhz ist der pegel tendenz weiter
steigend
und nun zur fußball bundesliga und damit
zitieren aber ja und da haben die bayern
heute auch gegen hoffenheim gewonnen
der vierte sieg in folge und der bvb der
hat endlich seine negativserie beendet
und angstgegner augsburg besiegte die
bisherigen ergebnisse des 19 spieltags
bayern gegen hoffenheim für 21 dortmund
gegen augsburg 31 frankfurt schlägt
härter mit dem neuen trainer pal dardai
ebenfalls drei zu eins union berlin und
gladbach trennen sich 1 1 ebenso bremen
und schalke das topspiel am abend
leipzig gegen leverkusen ausführlich bei
uns im aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr
bereits gestern stuttgart besiegte mainz
mit 2 zu 0 die tabelle bayern
unangefochtener spitzenreiter
dahinten leid dahinter leipzig frankfurt
jetzt dritter leverkusen vierter kann
aber heute abend wieder an der eintracht
vorbeiziehen
der bvb klettert auf platz 5 sechster
wolfsburg siebter gladbach die zweite
tabellenhälfte die beginnt mit stuttgart
ja und am tabellenende alles unverändert
köln sechzehnter meint siebzehnter und
schlusslicht schalke bei der wm am
königssee reichte es heute für
deutschlands vorzeige rodler felix loch
nur zur silbermedaille
doppelter deutsche erfolg dagegen bei
den doppelsitzern toni eggert und sascha
benecken haben es wieder geschafft zum
vierten mal nacheinander holen sie sich
den wm-titel nachdem im weltcup in
diesem winter die dominanz der deutschen
doppelsitzer etwas ins wanken gekommen
war jetzt ein doppelerfolg zum genau
richtigen zeitpunkt eggert benecken
verweisen mit bestzeiten in beiden
läufen ihre teamkollegen tobias wendl
und tobias arlt auf den silberrang
thüringer dürfen sich mit diesem erfolg
rekord weltmeister nennen
insgesamt haben die deutschen rodler
damit vor dem schlusstag morgen bereits
acht medaillen eingefahren
francesco friedrich hat zum vierten mal
den gesamtweltcup im zweierbob gewonnen
der 30 jährige holte auch beim weltcup
finale in innsbruck eine souveränen sieg
ja und der deutsche kombinierer eric
frenzel der hat heute am zweiten tag des
nordic triple in seefeld eine starke
leistung gezeigt und ist auf platz vier
vor gestimmt dabei lag der rekord
weltmeister nach einem bestenfalls
durchschnittlichen sprung zunächst nur
auf rang 8 zeigte dann aber eine
hervorragende laufleistung und holte auf
den tagessieger die norweger jan magnus
rieber fast 50 sekunden auf webber
seinerseits gewann das rennen klar mit
mehr als einer halben minute vorsprung
vor dem japaner akito watabe und dem
finnen ilka haben auf den plätzen vier
bis sechs dann mit eric frenzel vinzenz
geiger und fabian rießle drei deutsche
kombinierer die morgen allesamt noch
chancen auf einen podestplatz haben solo
segler boris herrmann ist für das
bundesverdienstkreuz vorgeschlagen
worden
der 39 jährige hatte als erster
deutscher an der vendée globe
teilgenommen und wurde nach 80 tägiger
weltumseglung fünfter nachdem er kurz
vor dem zielhafen mit einem fischerboot
kollidiert war ja morgen eine 45 minuten
sportreportage extra sendung dazu über
boris herrmann und diese härteste
segelregatta der welt waren die glut 17
10 tolle voran
nach einer fast überall eiskalten nacht
erwartet uns morgen viel sonnenschein
die details gleich vom beim wetter von
es denn terry
das war es von uns schön dass sie dabei
waren claus kleber erwartet sie um drei
viertel elf zum heute-journal und wir
sind um 19 uhr am morgen wieder zur
stelle
einen schönen samstagabend wünschen wir
tschüss
[Musik]
einen schönen abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die kaltluft setzt
sich deutlich weiter in den süden durch
und die tiefste hier von westen heran
rauschen die haben erst einmal keine
chance und so stabilisiert sich das
wetter und es gibt mehr sonnenschein
schauen wir in die nacht da lösen sie
schon die wolken im norden auf und es
klart immer weiter auf ansonsten in der
mitte schneefall und nach süden auch
regen dabei
es wird hier in der mitte glatten nach
norden sowieso hier hat sich eine
schneedecke ausgebildete und dort sinken
die temperaturen teils auf -12
vielleicht sogar noch etwas darunter
und auf 5 grad im südwesten deutschlands
morgen gibt es nach langer dunkelheit
endlich wieder viel sonne scheint für
die meisten in deutschland nur nach
nordosten hin ergibt ein paar wolken
mehr und einige flocken und im südwesten
bleibt es dicht mit regen und schnee und
die temperaturen erreichen dabei -2 grad
im osten hier also dauerfrost und 7 grad
im südwesten deutschlands die kommenden
tage bringen schon wieder neuen regen
aus dem südwesten im osten deutschlands
und nach norden bleibt es weiterhin kalt
bei minus 1 bis 11 grad und ab dienstag
wird es deutlich wärmer mit viel regen
ein schöner abend